Wir sprechen jetzt über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da sind 6 Spieltage gespielt und es sieht ganz gut aus für die einen Teams und bei anderen wurden schon die Träne entlassen. Wir sprechen jetzt drüber mit einem Fokus auf Fortuna Düsseldorf und den 1. FC Nürnberg, mit Fadi Keblawi vom Kadeb Podcast und nn.de und mit Gianni Koster, chefreporter Sport bei der Rheinischen Post, jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Aber andererseits, es hat…
Ja, da bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Ein weiser Mann hat gesagt, mit den Punkten, da haben sie sich Zeit erkauft. Es ist noch gar nicht so lange her, dass das jemand gesagt hat. Und ein bisschen ist es da beim Klub auch so. Klar, es sind sieben Punkte nach sechs Spielen nicht perfekt, aber immerhin sind es sieben Punkte. Und gerade wenn man das eben anerkennt, was du sagst, dass der Klub bisher eigentlich nie so wirklich überlegen war, muss man ja auch dankbar sein für jeden Dreier, der darunter gefallen ist. Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber auch erst sechs Spiele, plus eben diesen krassen Umbruch auch im Kader. Also müsste man da jetzt nicht vielleicht auch mal sagen, Augen zu und jetzt mal der sportlichen Leitung erstmal vertrauen. Weil wenn Joti Catialexo Miroslav Klose haben wollte oder von ihm überzeugt ist– und da habe ich jetzt nichts anderes gehört, korrigier mich bitte ansonsten gerne– dann muss man sagen, ja gut, also mindestens eine Halbserie, so wie Gianni eigentlich, nur halt quasi aus der anderen Haltung heraus. Gianni sagt, für mich zählt es erst ab Weihnachten. Bis dahin bin ich mal ganz vorsichtig erstmal. Natürlich aus der Luxushaltung heraus aktueller Tabellenführer. Aber im Grunde müsste man doch das als Minimum auch Klose und Catialexo und dem ganzen Unfeld geben.
Ja, ja. Offiziell ist es auch noch so, dass der Sportvorstand keine Trainer-Diskussion beginnen will, die natürlich längst begonnen hat in Nürnberg. Und es ist halt auch aus Erfahrung so, dass sich irgendwann die Punktausbeute eher den Leistungen anpasst als umgekehrt. Und es war bisher wirklich viel zu wenig. Und es gibt auch keine wirkliche Reaktion, auch während der Spiele auf irgendwelche Probleme, die sich da auftun, kommt da von der Trainerbank relativ wenig. Und zum großen Umbruch, den gab es tatsächlich. Allerdings gegen die Hertha, am Samstag waren sieben Spieler in der Startelf, die in der vergangenen Saison schon beim 1. FC Nürnberg angestellt waren. Also da relativiert sich die ganze Sache dann auch wieder. Weil die müssten einander eigentlich kennen. Ich glaube wirklich, ich würde gerne positive Dinge sagen, aber nicht, dass dieses Projekt Zukunft hat über die nächste Länderspielpause hinaus.
Muss ich kurz überlegen, Mitte Oktober ist das, das ist schon relativ bald.
Ja, ich glaube zwei Spiele sind es jetzt noch, oder? Und dann ist Länderspielpause. Also es kommt jetzt das Auswärtsspiel in Hannover und dann Heimspiel gegen Münster. Es gibt Menschen im Verein, die auch da sehr inoffiziell sagen, dass man aus diesen beiden Spielen vielleicht vier Punkte holen sollte. Das sehe ich im Moment nicht so kommen.
Meine Erkenntnis ist auf jeden Fall schon nach diesem Rasenfunk, niemals Stress mit Fadi anfang.
Den wirst du nicht bekommen, es sei denn, du wirst Trainer des ersten FC Nürnberg oder Sportverstand.
Ja, und trotzdem finde ich es aber auch, also ich verstehe natürlich, was du sagst und meine Güte, warum habe ich den Club hier ausgewählt als Schwerpunkt, weil ich schon auch mitbekommen habe, das läuft gerade nicht so und die Sachen, die ich gesehen habe, waren jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich da auf Knien niedergegangen bin, ob der schönen Spielkunst des Clubs. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber halt auch so deprimierend, dass man keinerlei Zeit in diesem Geschäft bekommt und bei allen, also ich verstehe alles, was du sagst. Ich habe eigentlich auch keine Gegenargumente, außer das eine wäre es nicht irgendwie schön, wenn man einmal ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben könnte.
Mein Kollege Uli Dijkmaier hat tatsächlich am Sonntag auf NNDE einen Kommentar verfasst, in dem er mehr oder weniger sich das erste Mal in der Geschichte dieses Verlagshaus dafür entschuldigt, dass da möglicherweise demnächst ein Trainer rausfliegen könnte, weil alle Miroslav Klose die Zeit geben wollen würden, wenn nicht von Beginn an die Zweifel daran bestanden hätten, dass er in diesem Job vielleicht nicht der Richtige ist, was ja auch einfach mal sein kann.
Ich meine, wenn du mit Leuten im Alltag sprichst, das werdet ihr wahrscheinlich auch gemacht haben.
Exakt.
Interesse, aber Fadi?
Ja, bitte, Entschuldigung.
Mit Blick auf– ich habe gerade mal den Staff da aufgerufen von Nürnberg, um so ein bisschen zu gucken, wer eigentlich dahintersteht, und neben der Überraschung, dass es auch in Nürnberg ein Head of Performance gibt.
Auch ein sehr gutes Thema, wenn man auf die Laufleistungen und die intensiven Läufe dann blickt. Da wundert sich auch einige.
Da gibt es ja unterschiedliche Interpretationen, was dieser Head of Performance überhaupt so machen soll, aber ohne jetzt Jens Bauer und Rabih Pinola zu nahe treten zu wollen, stelle ich mir halt eben einfach die Frage, wenn man jetzt grundsätzlich nicht sagt, man will sich nicht verrennen in so einem Projekt, Miroclose, wenn man jetzt einfach merkt, warum auch immer, in Klammern, das hätte man natürlich dann ja auch schon vor seiner Anstellung irgendwie wissen können, wenn man ihn so ein bisschen beobachtet hätte bei seiner letzten Trainerstation, ob da nicht vielleicht noch so die letzte Notbremse wäre, zu sagen, da kommt noch ein bisschen Erfahrung in diesen Trainerstab rein, also dass man so jemanden holt, ich kann mich dran erinnern, Eine Fortuna hat das gemacht mit dem Manni Stewes, langjähriger Wegbegleiter von Lucien Favre bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Dass man halt sagt, man holt da noch jemanden dazu, der dieses Geschäft super, super, super gut kennt, der vielleicht Ruhe reinbringt, der dem Trainer auch einfach Aufgaben abnehmen kann, wo er sich aber hundertprozentig darauf verlassen kann, dass er dich, dass er sozusagen jetzt nur noch in so einem Lernmodus das und dies übernimmt und damit dann auch nicht so die Gefahr ist, dass er sich so verhaspelt. Also das fände ich jetzt persönlich, glaube ich. Und dann bin ich ja bei Max, weil ich halt sage, das ist ja gerade diese Krux in diesem Geschäft, dass man erstens so oft daneben liegt. Da muss man ja einfach die Frage stellen, woran liegt das? Warum sind so viele Personaleinscheidungen einfach falsch? Und zweitens, wieso gibt man dem Ganzen dann nicht Zeit, wenn man versucht, wenn man nicht jetzt grundsätzlich sagt, es geht einfach nicht. Das gibt es ja auch, dass man einfach merkt, man hat sich für jemand entschieden, funktioniert dann aber menschlich einfach dann doch nicht. Okay, dann muss es halt eine Trennung geben oder eine Entscheidung geben. Aber in dem Fall würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen, so aus der neumal klugen Sicht aus dem Rheinland heraus, das ist eine Leichttätel ja ganz gut, wenn man ihm Hilfe gibt.
Ja, die Diskussion gibt es in Nürnberg natürlich auch. Es gab ja 2009 war das, glaube ich, mit Michael Oening auch einen jungen, unerfahrenen Trainer, dem dann Peter Herrmann zur Seite gestellt wurde.
Der ewige Peter.
Genau, er wird auch derzeit wieder gefordert. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das so wichtig ist, dass du einen erfahrenen hast. Ich glaube einfach, wenn fachlich alles stimmt, dann können da auch vier 17-jährige Co-Trainer, Head of Performance und sonstige sein. Dann funktioniert es, wenn es fachlich und in der Ansprache an die Mannschaft und an die Öffentlichkeit funktioniert. Und all das sehe ich halt einfach im Moment in Nürnberg nicht. Das, ja, das ist…
Und welche Rolle spielt da denn der Kader, der ja nicht von Miroslav Klose zusammengestellt wurde? Also es ist ja nicht nur der Trainer.
Nee, Kader, da sind tatsächlich in Nürnberg immer noch, nachdem jetzt über drei, vier Jahre immer die Kader-Zusammenstellung kritisiert wurde, muss man nämlich auch noch immer ein Einschränkung dazu sagen, dass hier in den letzten Jahren selten mal Trainer kritisiert worden sind, wenn sie nicht Markus Weinziel hießen, sondern Robert Klaus und Christian Fjell haben in der Öffentlichkeit relativ viel Kredit bekommen. Und da hieß es immer, denen wurde der falsche Kader hingestellt, was ja glaube ich auch wirklich die coolere Variante ist, dass es nicht die Schuld des Trainers ist, sondern des Menschen, der die Mannschaft zusammenstellt. In dieser Saison glaube ich, dass das tatsächlich ein bisschen anders ist, dass die Mannschaft vielleicht sogar besser ist als die des Vorjahrs. Ich glaube, der Sportvorstand hat da, nachdem er dann auf seinen Posten berufen wurde, noch ein paar Transfers, die schon geplant waren, so hört man es zumindest auch nochmal abgesagt und nochmal neu, darum gebeten, ins Scouting zu gehen. Und ich betonte auch, dass in Nürnberg sich am Scouting, auch was Datenscouting betrifft, sehr viel ändern muss. Und dass er das vielleicht ein bisschen anders erwartet hätte, bei einem Fußball-Zweitligisten im Jahr 2024. Und ja, deshalb, die Mannschaft ist okay zusammengestellt. Also ich glaube nicht so, dass es Julian Justwahn gibt, der bewiesen hat, dass er ein überdurchschnittlicher, Entschuldigung, Zweitligaspieler sein kann. Also die Mannschaft müsste eigentlich besser Fußball spielen können. Als es derzeit tut.
Also Robin Knoche sicherlich noch ein bekannter Name für die Innenverteidigung. Danilo Zsoares, Florian Pick aus Heidenheim. Das sind jetzt nur ein paar der vielen Neuzugänge, aber ich wollte mal so ein paar Namen nennen, die vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen kennen.
Genau. Caspar Janda, bislang bester Spieler der Saison vom MSV Duisburg gekommen. Ein sehr talentierter Mittelfeldspieler, Stefanos Tsimas, der die rote Karte in Ulln gesehen hat. Ein griechischer Unnationalspieler, auch mit sehr guten Anlagen. Es ist schon ein bisschen Fantasie dabei, Robin Knoche. Suarez und Pikk, weil du die genannt hast, die sahen bislang in dieser Saison noch nicht so gut aus, obwohl sie so ein Teil der neuen Achse sind. Und was man dann in der Kaderzusammenstellung beim 1. FC Nürnberg seit Jahren oder seit einiger Zeit immer wieder erwähnen muss, ist, dass es keine wirkliche Konkurrenz für Florian Flick auf der 6. gibt. Und der jetzt schon ein paar Mal bewiesen hat, dass er im Spielaufbau vielleicht nicht der Pressing-Resistenteste ist. Also wenn man an dieser Kaderzusammenstellung was unbedingt kritisieren muss, dann ist es, dass auf der Position jetzt wiederholt nicht gehandelt wurde, um da neue Akzente setzen zu können.
Okay, also wenn ich dann aber jetzt mal versuche, ein Zwischenfazit zu ziehen, denn was anderes kann das ja nach sechs Spieltagen noch gar nicht sein, dann sehe ich Umbruch im Kader angegangen, aber da sind auf jeden Fall noch Themen offen. Umbruch auf der Trainerposition, aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach nicht zufriedenstellend erfüllt. Da wird vermutlich noch etwas passieren. Situation des Gesamtvereins. Stimmung nehme ich schon wieder als relativ gereizt wahr. Was wahrscheinlich mit den sportlichen Leistungen zusammenhängt, war aber– ich komme ja aus der Ecke– nie anders beim Klub.
Man muss wirklich die gesamte Stimmungslage jetzt unter dem Eindruck der vergangenen 24 Monate betrachten. Wie ich vorhin schon mal sagte, da hat sich sehr viel Frust angestaut. Unabhängig davon, die fachliche Bewertung von Miroslav Klose, das Arbeit bislang als Trainer, ist halt auch einfach unzureichend.
Aber das heißt, wir befinden uns quasi in einem Zwischenstadium. Im Grunde, weil wenn wir jetzt quasi uns die Tabelle angucken würden und einfach so täten, als wäre Dieter Hecking noch im Amt und als wäre noch Trainer XY da, dann wäre es ja genauso wie immer eigentlich beim Klub.
Ja.
Das heißt, wir haben quasi als Zwischenfazit, der Umbruch ist eingeleitet, es ist aber noch an keiner Stelle außerhalb quasi beim Kader und so weiter zu erkennen, dass sich schon etwas nach vorne bewegt hätte. Es hat sich nur viel verändert.
Genau. Und der Fußball ist schlechter geworden als zum Beispiel in der Anfangszeit von Christian Vell, der auch nicht sehr viel bessere Ergebnisse geliefert hat. Aber zu Beginn der vergangenen Saison war es eben, dass in Nürnberg die Menschen wieder gerne in Stadion gegangen sind, weil da so ein Ansatz einer Spielidee zu erkennen war. Jetzt im Moment noch nicht.
Im Moment noch nicht. Aber das kann sich erinnern. Fadi, ich bin sehr gespannt. Man kann es ja dann bei euch im KDEP Podcast hautnah verfolgen. Ich zähle jetzt schon die Spiele bis zur Länderspielpause runter. Interessantes Phänomen übrigens, dadurch, dass Miroslav Klose anders ist als viele Trainer, dadurch, dass er ehrlicher ist als viele andere Menschen, mit denen man im Fußball zu tun hat, kenne ich mit der einen Einschränkung, dass es manchmal schwierig ist, über ihn Geschichten zu schreiben, kenne ich aber ganz wenige Leute aus unserer Branche, die nicht irgendwie Miroslav Klose gönnen würden, Erfolg zu haben. Das ist ein sehr interessantes Phänomen.
Das ist exakt so in Nürnberg auch, ja.
Aber deswegen muss man auch kein guter Trainer sein. Ich nenne es den Floh-Kofeld-Effekt. Grüße nach Darmstadt. Ich lasse mich vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Bitte löscht die Missgabeln wieder. Ich bin ja noch offen, mich umstimmen zu lassen. Aber eine gewisse Grundskepsis bleibt. Ihr zwei, das war sehr, sehr schön, mit euch über die 2. Liga zu sprechen. Wir könnten jetzt auch locker noch eine Stunde weiterreden, aber irgendwann muss man ja auch einfach mal sagen, hier ist jetzt ein Punkt, an dem sind die wichtigsten Dinge gesagt. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Gianni Koster von der Rheinischen Post. Danke dir, Gianni, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Und herzlichen Dank an Fadi Keblawi, die Säule, wenn man über den Club sprechen will. Danke dir, dass du hier warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank.
Und ich danke euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, natürlich auch, denn ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Wenn ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt, dann auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und wenn ihr das bisher noch nicht getan habt, dann probiert es doch mal aus. Es ist gar nicht so schwierig. Und getan haben das unter anderem der Igel, Volker, Felix Jakob, Fabian, Jonathan, Lindy Spindi und Olli. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club gegangen und haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Das geht nämlich auf dieser Seite auch. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Danke, wenn ihr diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt und danke, wenn ihr uns weiter treu bleibt. Es gibt hier noch weitere Sendungen im Rasenfunk in dieser Woche. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.